we all have our own demons you used to
be one thing now you're something else
are you gonna behave yourself no I have
no problems you stick around do you
people do bad come on girl dude so many
snacks so little time Eddie you look
lousy I have a parasite venom say you
live get Misha Kim this cinimala what's
up everybody
I hope you enjoyed that new venom TV
spot trailer we are now only officially
10 days away from its release so we
could expect a couple more of these TV
spot trailers until then and even after
it comes out so there are only a couple
of new scenes here but I think that they
are some of the best that we've seen out
of all the trailers and the first one is
a full reveal of riot riot looks amazing
he's super big and super intense look at
his hands they really like claws and his
fingers are like knives they're super
sharp now riot has the ability to turn
his hands into a vast array of weapons
again we've seen his hands basically
turned into giant knives we've seen his
hands turn into giant axe blades and
we've even seen it in one trailer turn
into a flail which is really like a
medieval weapon that is a spiked ball on
a chain so riot is super intense and he
definitely seems stronger than venom at
least at first until Eddie Brock and the
Venom symbiote figure out a way to kind
of mesh well together we then have this
shot of venom jumping off of a rocket
right before it blows up this is no
doubt part of a scene that we've seen
before in a previous TV spot trailer
where venom and riot are fighting on a
rocket ship and again in that scene that
we saw it sort of seems like riot has
the upper hand on venom ripping the
Venom symbiote apart this is most likely
going to be a huge scene in the movie
most likely the final battle if not one
of the last scenes in the movie because
if you also take a look at the last
poster that was released you can see the
rocket ship on the
left side so it's important enough to
include in this poster which probably
means it's a big scene in the movie so
there you have it the new venom TV spot
trailer let me know what you think about
it and let me know what you think about
the full reveal of riot a reminder about
the giveaway I'm doing I'm giving away a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]